so explain the velocity of what they're
doing because obviously they're
outpacing
some venture firms here in the valley
and
those are venture firms that have
massive infrastructure in this space
they
they don't have that same infrastructure
do they they they don't and
it's funny so i pulled for for this i
pulled some some data from crunchbase
um and this was pretty funny so through
april 20th
just this month tiger has been the
leader co-lead on investment rounds
totaling 2.5 billion dollars um
they're saying in the first four months
of the year no the first 20 days of this
month
the first 20 days of this month they and
of course they didn't do all of these
rounds but even if they just did
30 of that 2.5 billion that's 750
million dollars
announced this month with 10 days to go
left in the month that's an entire
like you know medium-sized growth fund
at this point so
you're right that that the pace and the
velocity is completely
unprecedented um and i think the best
way to explain it i actually loved what
brad said
on on the all in pod uh your last
episode when you brought him up brad
gerstner from
altimeter yes yes brad gerstner from
altimeter
um and he said something like i believe
if you own an index fund
of the top 30 of technology companies
over the next 10 years
you'll be incredibly well rewarded and
so that kind of goes to
what i think tiger's ultimately doing
and i didn't touch on this
that much in the essay itself but
ultimately they're they're
you know on a micro basis yes they might
overpay here for for a deal or they
might
you know invest in one deal that ends up
being a fraud or a couple deals that end
up being fraud
but if they're able to invest in
basically the broad asset class
and get a well-diversified basically
create an index fund
of the series b kind of pre-ipo
asset class i think that is a product
that is very attractive
to lps and and like if you came to
somebody and said hey
if you could invest in an index fund of
this type of asset would you do it a lot
of folks would say absolutely yes
but the only way that you can do that is
by adopting a strategy
in adopting a way of investing where you
are
investing at you know you're turning the
dial to 11. and you're you're you know
you're not doing as much diligence
you're not joining boards you have
basically this product
to founders that allows you to come in
be like okay i like this founder i'm
gonna write them a term sheet today
which is what they've developed well you
know and it's not unprecedented we
obviously had wework do this before that
we had yuri milner do it
we've had this tradition in silicon
valley when things are super hot
people zip in and just say i'm gonna
overpay what was the last round on
twitter what was the last round of
facebook i'll come over the top
i'll pay more it does not matter i'll
look like a sucker today
and i'll look like i'm overpaying today
but in the future i might not so
thinking out loud here the ramification
for our industry
is that that zone before the ipo
but after let's say product market fit
and getting to 25 million in revenue
to pick a number because are they
dabbling in companies under 25 million
in revenue you think
you you see it very occasionally but
very rarely are they leading around
they'll like participate with somebody
but
very very rarely addition will do it
more edition's been doing some some a's
and stuff but tiger very rarely
so when you have tiger sort of taking
over the space and they're not the only
ones obviously dan rose formerly of
facebook and
um amazon the only person i know who
worked for both pesos
and zuckerberg both in their formative
years and he'll let you know
and he'll let you know that and he was a
great guest on the podcast where he
explained it all
uh great guy um yeah i love you dan
sorry love you dance sorry
i didn't i didn't throw the elbow there
that was a young gun here throwing
elbows off the bench
but uh what is interesting there is
that area then becomes let's say
um non-differentiated capital
it's just as i would tell founders ten
years ago
when you get to that time it's like you
look at the term sheets whoever gave you
the best deal
you know highest valuation lowest you
know rights and change in
anything to do with the company's
charter and you know how it's run
yep you kind of just take whatever the
best deal is because they're they're
buying one to
five or maybe 10 of the company and
they're and they're typically overpaying
for it
so that means the venture game is now
gonna be
25 million and under that's the game or
is this mean that that game 25 million
in revenue to when you go public is the
game
if you see what i'm saying i i do and i
i think
both are correct like i think i think
the game has completely changed and now
there's a separate game
on on the the post kind of like series
beer post product market fit post 25
million
and now there's a new game at the early
stage i think the early stage
still resembles a lot of kind of what we
thought of as like this traditional
venture
um asset class uh where you know you
you build really strong relationships
you join the board et cetera et cetera
uh whereas the growth market now it's
funny it's like
the the the hilarious truth is that the
like one of the best investment
strategies in venture growth the series
being beyond over the last five years
is looking at a sas company just meeting
every sas company you can
and finding the one that is growing the
fastest and paying whatever the market
clearing price is
some of the best sas investors i know
can barely do algebra
like they are not they are not quants
they're not you know deeping you know
digging into spreadsheets
but they can connect the dots on a net
new arr chart and they know how to do
like
net dollar retention and logo retention
those three things are all that have
mattered
for the last five years um and so it is
this entirely new game
at the growth-ish stage that is defined
i think by scale and by the ability to
move very quickly and that is why you've
seen co2 kick a lot of ass in the last
three years
or you've seen tiger kick a lot of ass
in the in the last three years because
they're built for it like their firms
literally have been doing high velocity
high scale investing
for decades in the public markets and
they are more much more
kind of able to bring that down into
private markets and play this sort of
game
um than than folks that you know really
look like venture firms
but have been dabbling in growth um just
because
they you know it's an easy way to make
returns and kind of bolt on
um so i i do think it's a different game
on both sides but i also think that like
there's plenty of situations and plenty
of founders that are still not going to
go with the tiger
crossover type product at any round um
and we can go into that as well but but
i'll stop there